Okay. The David Pakman show subreddit is rapidly
approaching 14,000 subscribers, one of the
largest progressive independent media subreddits
out there. Some interesting spose posts I
spotted this morning@davidpakman.com slash
r e. D. D. It. Yes, it is official. The next
democratic debate, debate number three has
been consolidated to one night only thanks
to several candidates who have ended their
campaigns and several candidates who have
not qualified for debate number three.
So what we've had happen between debate two
and debate three, uh, first of all, five Democratic
candidates ended their campaigns. Mike Ravel,
who I've interviewed, uh, John Hickenlooper,
Jay Inslee, Seth Moulton, most recently Kirsten
Gillibrand have all ended their presidential
campaigns that takes five away. In addition
to that, billionaire Tom Stier, congresswoman
Tulsi Gabbert and new age guru and author
Marianne Williamson, have failed to qualify
for debate number three because they are polling
below 2%. I believe all three of them had
the number of donors required 130,000 but
none of the three made the polling requirements
and thus they will not be on the debate stage
for debate number three how long they will
continue their campaigns. Given that they
did not make the debates, I don't know the
answer to. So the third debate on September
12th will be 10 candidates all on one night.
There's upside and there's downside to this.
The upside is when you split the candidates
on two nights you don't get to see all the
candidates interact with each other.
So like if Warren and Biden are on different
nights a, you might glean that there are differences
in policy between the two but you won't actually
get the opportunity to see them talk to each
other. So I like the fact that this is all
going to happen on one night. The downside
is that with 10 people up on the stage, you
are not going to get depth in any significant
way. You are not going to get detail about
policy. You are not really going to be able
to figure out who knows three talking points
and who actually understands these issues
in any kind of significant depth. But the
number is reducing and we are starting to
whittle down and get closer and closer to
an eventual nominee. Also from the David Pakman
show, sub reddit, much less serious for sure.
David Pacman's haircut. Uh, semper Fi, two
to five says I'm a big fan of David and I've
been watching for awhile.
I guess this is a little bit more a political
has. I am curious about what David tells his
Barbara when he gets his haircuts. First of
all, how dare you. I don't go to a barber.
I go to a hairdresser at a salon not getting
a dry cut. Are you crazy? I'm half kidding
by the way. Uh, his haircuts have been on
point lately and I would like to get the same
one. Thanks a lot. All I do, I go to the same
person. Um, what I found in my experience
is that I'm never thrilled with my haircuts.
And so when I find someone that does a satisfactory
haircut, I just keep going back to the same
person and I say just the trim scissors all
around, no buzzers. I used to get, you know,
like a real high and tight when I was younger.
No more of that, just trim it. Here's how
I comb it. Here's where my part is. That's
all we've got to do and it seems to be working
pretty well for me. So I dunno. Maybe bring
a picture of me if the, you're really determined
to have my hairstyle. Join the David Pakman
show subreddit, as you can see for both serious
political discussion and also nonsense related
to the show@adavidpakman.com slash reddit
it's crazy that this is my job, right? I mean
it's hard to believe.